también liberan contaminantes dañinos locales
que amenazan nuestra salud aquí y ahora.
Durante todo este tiempo me concentré en el riesgo ambiental a largo plazo
cuando debería haber protestado
por el impacto inmediato en la salud de los contaminantes en el aire.
La contaminación es una crisis de la salud pública.
Mata a siete millones de personas por año,
cuesta USD 5 billones a la economía mundial
y, lo que es peor, nos roba nuestro don más precioso,
nuestros años de vida:
seis meses de esperanza de vida en mi ciudad natal, París,
y hasta tres, cuatro o cinco años en lugares de India o China.
En EE. UU., muere más gente por emisiones de los tubos de escapes de los autos
que por accidentes de tránsito.
Entonces, ¿cómo nos protegemos de la contaminación?
Esto es difícil porque hay falta de información.
Carecemos de los datos para entender a lo que estamos expuestos.
Y eso es porque el modo en que hoy se monitoriza la calidad del aire no está
diseñado para ayudarnos a respirar, sino para ayudar a los gobiernos.
Muchas grandes ciudades tienen estaciones de monitorización de la calidad del aire
como esta de Londres,
para decidir cuándo cortar el tráfico o cuándo cerrar las fábricas.
Y estas máquinas son como las computadoras de los años 60
que ocupaban salas enteras.
Son increíblemente precisas, pero increíblemente grandes,
pesadas, costosas...
tanto que solo se pueden instalar algunas de ellas,
y no se pueden mover.
Para los gobiernos, la contaminación se ve así.
Pero para el resto de nosotros,
la calidad del aire se ve así.
Cambia todo el tiempo:
hora tras hora, calle por calle,
hasta ocho veces en una manzana de una ciudad.
Y aún más del interior al exterior.
Así que, a menos que caminen cerca de una de estas estaciones,
estas no les indican qué se debe respiran.
¿Cómo se vería la protección ambiental
si estuviera diseñada para la era del teléfono inteligente?
Durante los pasados tres años
mi equipo y yo estuvimos construyendo una tecnología
que ayuda a saber lo que respiramos
y cabe en la mano.
"Flow" es un rastreador personal de la calidad del aire que pueden llevar
en una mochila, una bicicleta o un cochecito.
Tiene muchos sensores en miniatura
que controlan los contaminantes más importantes en el aire,
como los óxidos de nitrógeno,
las emisiones de los autos,
o el material particulado que entra en nuestra sangre
y crea embolias y problemas cardíacos.
O los compuestos orgánicos volátiles,
los miles de químicos en los productos cotidianos
que terminamos respirando.
Eso hace que estos datos sean viables
y nos ayuda a entender lo que respiramos
al decirnos dónde y cuándo hemos estado expuestos a un aire de pobre calidad,
y que podemos tomar decisiones informadas
para empezar a actuar.
Podemos cambiar los productos usados en casa,
encontrar el mejor camino para ir en bicicleta,
salir a correr cuando la contaminación no está tan elevada
y encontrar el mejor parque para llevar a los niños.
Así creamos mejores hábitos para reducir nuestra exposición a la contaminación
y, al monitorizar la calidad del aire a su alrededor,
los ciclistas, los viajeros y los padres
contribuirán a trazar un mapa de la calidad del aire en su ciudad.
No solo construimos un dispositivo,
además, construimos una comunidad.
El verano pasado
enviamos prototipos de nuestra tecnología a 100 voluntarios en Londres
y entre todos trazaron un mapa de la calidad del aire
a través de más de 1600 km de aceras
y el 20 % de Londres central.
Nuestro objetivo ahora es llevarlo a nivel mundial
reunir los datos para trazar un mapa de la calidad del aire en cada calle,
para crear una base de datos sin precedentes,
para que así los científicos puedan estudiar la contaminación
y empoderar a los ciudadanos, líderes civiles y actores políticos
a apoyar políticas de aire limpio, para que surja un cambio.
Porque esto puede y debe cambiar.
¿Recuerdan los cigarrillos en los bares?
Llevó décadas de estudios sobre cáncer de pulmón y el tabaquismo pasivo,
pero alcanzamos un punto crítico y pasamos leyes que prohíben fumar.
Para la calidad del aire debemos alcanzar el mismo punto crítico.
Durante los últimos años
los gobiernos han multado a los fabricantes de autos
por engaños sobre las emisiones.
Las ciudades cobran tasas de congestión o construyen sendas para ciclistas,
como París, que transformó esta autopista
junto a mi casa, en medio de la ciudad,
en un parque costero.
Y ahora, los intendentes en todo el mundo consideran prohibir totalmente el diésel
hacia 2025, 2030 o 2035.
Pero ¿cuánto más rápido podríamos ir, cuántas más vidas podríamos salvar?
La tecnología sola no resolverá el cambio climático,
ni hará desaparecer la contaminación del aire repentinamente.
Pero puede hacer que la calidad del aire sea mucho más transparente,
y si damos poder a la gente
para que tomen medidas a fin de mejorar su salud,
entonces juntos podremos actuar para terminar con la contaminación.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)